he certainly didn't come across as
anybody who was out to Swindle you you
just brainstorm and then we execute
ideas and we fine-tune them he didn't
come across as anybody who had you know
evil in his heart you know how can we be
better in this how can we be better in
that or wanted to hurt anybody or who
you couldn't trust we've been doing this
for some time now and we immediately
respond to those concerns he didn't come
across as any of those things
it's it doesn't become less bizarre when
I when I tell you the details he was
running a nursing home company and he
all of a sudden becomes one of the
biggest mine owners in Appalachia I
guess I would almost call it a
restoration economy where restoring the
environment he called himself an
environmentalist he was going to save
the planet and save the coal industry he
had a scheme to fund Reclamation to us
it seemed like circular logic from the
beginning struggled to make his loan
payments to the state abandon his plans
dashing hopes he had raised in the town
it was always just you know some great
thing that was about to happen the check
was in the mail
but it never was if somebody asked me my
advice about doing business with Tom
Clark I'd say run and hide
[Music]
what's going on man
why
so what you gonna do
I don't really believe in missions for
papers it's just try to be an honest
old-fashioned newspaper print what's
interesting and true and informative and
there we are
I first heard about Tom Clark first
heard his name in February 2014 when he
bought the Natural Bridge of Virginia
that's what Rockbridge County is named
after so Natural Bridge is a big deal
here and the bridge was up for sale and
it's about 1600 acres of land and it was
going to get chopped into a pile of
different pieces and auctioned off and
people around here were horrified with
that notion
Tom Clark the community viewed him as
someone who wrote in here on a white
horse with a white hat who would save
Natural Bridge and could do God knows
what else to help the community
then he fell behind almost instantly in
his payments to the state and one of the
things that he told the state and he
told me was he was going to get into the
coal business
to make the payments for Natural Bridge
to the extent we could make thermal coal
cleaner you know we've got an
opportunity to actually be able to sell
more coal out of West Virginia
when Tom Clark came along the coal
industry he was in a really deep
downturn all the big coal companies went
broke
they were out of cash and they had a lot
of Old Mines that hadn't been cleaned up
yet
Federal Law requires that when a coal
mine operation is complete that they
restore the land back to its original
condition
restore it to its original Contours and
plant grass on it and clean up all the
poisoned water caused by the mining
activity
and so the big coal companies came up
with this plan to essentially shift
those obligations onto other people
and Tom Clark was one of the those other
people
he had no background in Coal whatsoever
he was in the Navy he worked in finance
and accounting jobs he built a nursing
home company that got really big at one
point like 100 nursing homes and then
sort of went broke and he ended up
taking a few of those homes and forming
a company called casito at Casita
Healthcare over 96 percent of our
patients would refer us to a friend and
to me you know that that certainly the
most unlikely person to take over
you know over a hundred Appalachian coal
mines
Tom Clark we had not heard of him before
he did not own any coal companies and
hadn't really been involved in mining
but he took on a bunch of permits that
were previously owned by Patriot Coal
Patriot Coal in the coal Fields is
sometimes called a liability dump
two of the biggest coal companies
Peabody and Arch spun off kind of their
unwanted minds and a lot of their health
care and pension obligations as separate
companies and then those two companies
merged and that's what Patriot is
and some people believe that from the
very beginning these companies were set
up to fail
so Patriot went bankrupt in 2015 and
that's where Tom Clark came in he
swooped in and said I'll take all those
Minds that nobody else wants he said he
was going to clean up all these old
derelict minds but he was also going to
develop this new market for carbon
neutral coal where the carbon emissions
from the coal would be offset by
planting trees somewhere else
when he said he was going to save the
coal industry and save the planet all at
once
I burst out laughing because it doesn't
make any sense
well I'm gonna get these mines I'm gonna
sell the coal for a little bit more
because I'm gonna plant trees all over
the place and the consumers of coal are
going to be happy to pay a little more
knowing that I'm going to plant trees
well there wasn't any indication that he
was planting trees so that it could
plant trees and so this notion of
somehow I'm going to be a wonderful
shade of green coal mine operator
just give me a break
the idea of trees plus Minds has
challenges it's unclear who would buy
this Greener coal again Tom Clark I
guess we're sort of betting the farm
that we're going to create a market
environmentalists hated his idea they
didn't want him to find new ways to dig
more coal and so really from the
beginning there was no Prospect of a
market for this kind of coal package
with carbon credits that he was selling
I don't know if he had a grand plan
you know part of me thinks what he did
with Natural Bridge established his cred
in the environmental world
you're on this great environmentalist
I've saved Natural Bridge and I've done
it by sending out the Virginia
conservation Legacy fund for God's sake
who could argue with a name like that
Tom Clark and Kim McCoy of the Virginia
conservation Legacy fund let's give this
thing a round of applause
part of me thinks that he got Natural
Bridge in order to climb into the coal
business
and part of me thinks he just stumbled
from one thing into the other
Clark had a lot of stuff he had an iron
mine in Minnesota he had a gold mine in
California he also tried to Corner the
market on offshore oil and gas platforms
he owned a historic Coast Guard vessel
definitely more than a billion dollars
of assets
he was totally immobile but it was all
other people's money
[Music]
Clark did do a lot of coal mine
Reclamation he spent tens of millions of
dollars however eventually he just ran
out of money he just didn't have any
more and was unable to even do basic
maintenance
towards the end of his operation he
stopped paying the company that took all
the water samples to test all the water
around his Minds
when the state finally put his company
in receivership in 2020 they said that
they had issued something like 160
notices of violations
[Music]
it's a great question did he somehow
find a way of making money off of all
these deals
they all ended up in bankruptcy or
receivership of one kind or another but
is there some way he could have uh
shifted money to himself in somewhere
where
that nobody knows about Mr Clark you're
on the phone I am your father good
morning good morning
for his part he was forced to go into
court and basically say I'm totally
broke it's all gone
and if you look at the dozens of
lawsuits the creditors have brought
against him they've accused him of
improperly moving money around a lot but
oftentimes it's to take money from one
doomed project that's about to go
bankrupt and put it into another doomed
project that's also eventually gonna
fall out of his control anything else we
need to take up in this IP this morning
thank y'all
[Music]
at the time Clark was doing all this
stuff he was actually very chatty
he was talking to the media all the time
about his
Grand plans reforestation of West
Virginia it puts people back to work
it's part of the transition economy a
restoration economy you know we'd talk
on the phone fairly regularly
and say my lawyers tell me I shouldn't
talk to you and then he'd sing like a
bird
but since things went South and
virtually all of his companies collapsed
he's kind of
not
apparently in a position to talk to
anybody right now about it hi it's a
message for Tom Clark
this is Zach mitercon from Bloomberg
News I called emailed and and sent a
number of letters to various addresses
he uses but I never heard back
[Music]
this has been kind of an uncomfortable
Topic in West Virginia because when
Clark's company went broke the state
actually had to step in and place it in
this kind of unusual unprecedented
receivership because they were afraid
that the damage that this company could
cause if it was just allowed to go into
an uncontrolled bankruptcy could kind of
take down the entire coal industry
so they had to sort of get control of it
and essentially have a court appointed
receiver control it to keep it from
causing collateral damage
[Music]
well but he's not unique we have seen a
lot of Minds transferred to Coal
companies that don't seem like they're
really up for managing or reclaiming
those Minds
and in theory Regulators should be able
to stop these transfers from happening
if they don't think it's a good idea or
it won't work out they can try to stop
the transfers
and perhaps more importantly the states
want the coal mines transferred as well
because they don't want the Reclamation
liability to fall to the state agencies
so there's a lot of incentive for
Regulators to approve mine transfers
even if they're too really
weird guys like Tom Clark
[Music]
so in some ways Tom Clark is kind of the
Fall Guy he's the one who the coal
industry found who was willing to kind
of ride these old mines into the ground
he was the guy willing to hold the hand
grenade when it was about to go off
Tom you and and your vision for what
this can be is uh is truly a blessing to
Southern West Virginia he obviously was
seen as a Visionary because he was
written up and you know all these I've
empowered newspapers around the country
coal miners lives would be better again
and the environment would get strayed
and he'd fix all these things
Joe yeah anybody who says they're going
to do that if you believe it they're a
visionary
um
whether he was a Visionary or not time
will tell
[Music]
[Music]